the highly anticipated spider-man no way
home a sequel to 2017's spider-man
homecoming and 2019 spider-man far from
home is finally out in theaters
following a whole lot of rumors about
which characters from previous
spider-man franchises would appear major
spoilers for spider-man no way home
ahead in no way home peter parker is
dealing with the aftermath of his
identity as spider-man being revealed
overwhelmed by the attention and the
consequences he asked dr strange to use
magic to make his identity a secret once
again in the midst of doing so the
multiverse is opened and peter is
suddenly faced with a slew of villains
from other realities who have fought
alternate versions of spider-man those
spider-men toby maguire and andrew
garfield reprising their roles from sam
raimi's films and mark webb's films
respectively show up and help tom
holland's peter save the day as is
typical with any marvel movie no way
home is chock full of easter eggs for
dedicated fans to find and enjoy but
there's one line that even the most
dedicated fans may have missed in terms
of its deeper meaning and it has to do
with some behind the scenes drama in the
film while all three spider-men are
waiting for the villains to arrive to
face off against them toby maguire's
spider-man complains of his back
problems saying that all of his
web-slinging must have exacerbated the
issue andrew garfield's spider-man then
helps him crack his back in a charming
and humorous bit before the action
commences but this bit actually has a
deeper meaning and references some
real-life back problems in maguire's
that played a part in his negotiations
for 2004's spider-man 2. as reported by
variety in 2003 mcguire signed on for
spider-man 2 in a 17 million deal but
not before negotiations became a bit
tense during negotiations columbia
pictures allegedly felt that mcguire's
known back problems quote were now being
used as a threat during negotiations if
the actor's list of demands wasn't met
the studio even considered recasting
mcguire's role by replacing him with
jake gyllenhaal who of course later went
on to star opposite holland and far from
home as mysterio luckily maguire's team
stepped in promising good behavior for
maguire as long as he received checkups
to assure his back was in good condition
the situation definitely sounds tense
which makes a reference in no way home
all the more fun now that all the drama
from the early 2000s is good for a laugh
toby maguire's back problems have become
infamous on hollywood circles so much so
that no way home didn't even contain the
first reference to the situation back in
sam raimi's spider-man 2 maguire's peter
parker is trying to get back into the
groove of this whole superhero thing he
tries to leap between buildings yelling
i'm back only to fall from a
considerable height
my back
open my back
as it turns out sam raimi was nervous
about including the line in the flick
because he didn't want to upset maguire
and told the bbc about a conversation he
had about the situation with his brother
producer ivan ramy he told the bbc
at first i thought that was really funny
and then i said you know ivan although i
think it's funny because we've had this
problem with toby maybe we better not do
it because i mean he has had a back
problem and then ivan says oh screw it
we'll just do it anyways for those who
know about the problem with toby's back
it'll be an inside joke and for those
who don't it should be funny just for
what it is while it wouldn't have made
or broke the film whether the line was
in it or not it would have been a fun
bit for people who kept up with all the
behind the scenes drama as luck would
have it maguire was game raymie told the
bbc i told toby i thought it would be
funny and he said you know what that
will be funny it's okay if they laugh at
me let them laugh at me i thought that
was very brave of him check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about no way home are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you